Project Options
In this tutorial, we'll explain project options in Burp Suite
and how you can save and load your favourite project options.
Project options include everything within the Project Options tab
at the top of Burp, and also everything within individual tools in their Options tab.
If you use an on-disk project, these options are automatically saved within the project data.
So any changes that you make are maintained when you reopen an existing project.
But you can also save project options to a configuration file so that you can use these again.
One way to do this is through the Project menu, go to Project Options, and Save Project Options.
So if I just give this a name, we've saved them.
You can also do this from individual configuration panels if you click the Save Options item from the gear icon.
This will just save the options for that single panel.
So if we restart Burp, when Burp reopens, we can select to use the configuration file that we saved.
This means that the new project will get created using those options that I saved to disk.
We can also load project options at any time through the Project menu, or within individual panels.
We can do the same thing through the gear icon and choose Load Options.
If you wish, you can configure Burp to always load your preferred config file by default for new projects.
So to do this, in the Startup Wizard, if you select your preferred config file and check this box that says Default to the above in future,
when you start and open a new project, Burp will select the same configuration file by default without you having to choose it.
So that's how project options work in Burp Suites, and how you can save and load your favorite options.
So that's how project options work in Burp Suites, and how you can save and build your favorite options.
So that's how you can save and build your favorite options.